I was a tech reporter and I was at
Newsweek when basically it went under
and in 2012 and I got laid off and I was
52 years old and I looked around and it
wasn't just that my company was going
out of business my business was going
out of business and I always wanted to
work at a tech company I always have
this idea of working at a startup they
always seem to be having so much more
fun than we were you know the
journalists you know you go visit these
guys and it looked like they're having a
blast right because they're all growing
the companies are making money they're
they're they're hiring rather than
laying off it spent the last 10 20 years
in companies where you're always waiting
for the next layoff so went to work at a
place called hub spot which makes
marketing software and it was like had
every startup cliche there in Boston so
I didn't have to move they had every
startup cliche you can imagine we have
the dogs in the office we had nap rooms
we had beanbag chairs which at age 52
you should not have conference rooms
with beanbag chairs because you can get
into the beanbag chair but you can't get
back out like there's no graceful way to
get out of a beanbag chair you know so
you see all these people kind of
crawling around on all fours after a
meeting which I thought was very
undignified they had the average age was
26
literally half my age right in almost
everybody's right out of college and
these like Bros who would like they have
pushup Club in the lobby at lunchtime
like doing their their bro thing like do
you even lift and and I didn't say a
very quickly realize there's like a
blend it was like a mix of a frat house
a Montessori kindergarten and a
Scientology compound right it was like
like all three things in what's right
and thank you so equal parts of each
they had a culture code they loved
culture they wanted to talk about
culture when I make culture overt and
explicit and we're going to create a
company that we love right and the
culture code basically just defined
how's what does it mean to be hub
spotting how do you belong to the cult
right like how do you fit in and they
have a couple of acronyms heart and warp
vork was value over replace from a
player which is like comes from baseball
pro baseball like why are we paying you
more than what we could pay the average
person to do your job which is a cruel
metric and the other one in my case I
thought they should have a negative book
because they were paying me a pretty
good salary and I did almost nothing
right so and Hart was you had to be
humble effective adaptable remarkable
and transparent right and at one point I
had to have a review with my boss who
was a guy not my in my for in a 40s say
but two grown men we had a cydnus little
tiny room and he had to give me a heart
score and I got a 2 and I kind of
thought like how has it happened that
two grown men are sitting in a room
having a discussion about such obvious
visible [ __ ] right like like this
like you know like heart what's your
heart score like and how it but it
sounded all scientific here's your
number we can we're data-driven
organization your heart is a to like why
I should be a zero right I'm have no
heart right
they had training when you joined and
they would talk about your superpower
like what's your superpower and they
would talk about this literally and I
would burst out laughing I'm the
journalist right like I mean you know
the journalist really don't like this
stuff so what's your superpower
what is your superpower we had around
there two weeks of training we had to
learn how to use the product but it was
really indoctrination right now they
would tell these kids do you know how
lucky you are to be here thousands of
people wanted the job that you got but
it's harder to get a job here than to
get into Harvard like which is totally
not true but anyway but um and so they
would feed them all this stuff and then
they would be like okay what's your
superpower then we had to go around and
tell something about ourselves that no
one knew that made us special and made
us a snowflake you know and like I don't
really you know have anything you know
and like one guy was I playing a heavy
metal band on weekends I go cool yeah I
was like well I oh I'm the only one in
this room who's had a colonoscopy right
and then they like they take a hose your
kids you won't believe this but I would
trust me this is coming for you right
they take a hose but they do give you
they give you pills you don't remember
it you know but you know they did it
right you know and they're just looking
at me like dude what is wrong with you
like nobody laughs right like no because
nobody laughs right
that was my superpower I am towards a
colonoscopy right I'm the only one here
to take lipitor I have high cholesterol
too you know so and then the main way to
succeed was just to be enthusiastic you
didn't have to do anything you just had
to be a team player like a total team
player you had to be GSD get [ __ ] done
and this is a real chalkboard HubSpot
equals cool like somebody at work just
stopped on their way to get coffee just
wrote Hubbs y equals cool on a
chalkboard like I don't know why right
they had a slogan one plus one equals
three right which you guys all did math
you know that's not true right but I
mean so one plus one equals three and
then they would say things like I like
that idea but I don't think it's one
plus one equals three enough you know
where Hobbes what we did you tell me a
little better I'm like
so up and they had tears for peers so
constantly people would be cheering for
chose because the way to get attention
or to get to move up in the organization
was to show that you gave praise to
other people it took me a long time to
figure this out so we would get these
praise Gazans I call them do like emails
with someone would say like oh my god I
just want to say that Ashley last way
kind of like crash that when she was
running a blog I ow
right but it would be to everyone right
everyone in the whole department would
get this hemo and then the protocol was
to reply to all you had to reply to all
thing
oh god Carl you go you know like woo who
asked if I president and like and if you
didn't reply to all like you look like a
c'mon right and then you Hema would fill
up with like a hundred emails from
people all saying the same [ __ ] to each
other right and for a while I would
ignore it then I thought like I'm
looking like a grumpy old guy so I
joined in would be like woohoo and I put
like 800 exclamation points you know and
then someone figured out like dude you
being a dick stop that right so uh so
I'm thinking like this place is not
right this place is really crazy and
then one day the founder there published
an article on LinkedIn he had a new
management breakthrough which is that he
really wants to always be solving for
the customer and so he would bring a
teddy bear to all of his management
meetings and they would have to talk to
the teddy bear as if it were a customer
that was - way to remind you to always
solve for the customer right so I'm like
okay this is officially not right like I
said I spent all these years writing
about Apple from the outside envisioning
it as this cult compound and now I'm
living in a real cult compound right
this is even crazier than I ever
imagined Apple even as a fiction writer
right so I sat desk to desk with this
guy who is like my boss he was like 12
and I was like and I was like dude hey
dude that thing with the teddy bear
that's crazy right and he's like whoa no
look I was like look no one else is
around you can tell me like we know it's
not right and he's like no if it gets
you know it's kind of eccentric but I
was like oh my god right so like like no
one will laugh at the teddy bear that
was even worse to me than the teddy bear
was the fact that no one would laugh at
it right so I called I called a friend
of mine who had left journalism and
become a marketing guy but had done it
successfully unlike me and I said well I
told him about the teddy bear I showed
me our clothes like is this normal like
man is this what it's like in the
corporate world I didn't know you know
he's like no dude this is Jonestown like
get out now let's run now let your your
sir one step run having to drink
kool-aid like literally they're going to
go around you can do the math suicide
the white robes the whole thing right so
and this is what meanwhile everybody
else look good this is a real picture
and this is how they were every day it
looks like it was like being in la-la
land it was I feel like living in a
musical
if this everybody was really really
happy right and I was not and it which
makes you miserable it makes it's crazy
make because like maybe something's
wrong with me because they are all
really really happy maybe the world has
changed and now people bring teddy bears
to work and that's cool and that's
normal right but as time went on I
realized I went going the wrong way
in fact it was that people weren't happy
when they did studies they did surveys
because they did relentless happiness
surveys they had very high turnover and
very low morale and that puzzled me too
but then I realized there were two
cultures it was a surface culture which
is all that crap then there was a real
culture right in the real culture was
that they had this huge sales
boiler-room this telemarketing boiler
room where they put me in for a while to
punish me for asking for a new job it
was like really really loud I had to
listen to this guy named noisy pee all
day long get on the phone and say the
same script over and over hey Bob how's
it going down in Orlando all the weather
down there yeah great but what's your
marketing plan for this year and they
click hang up start again right
smile and dial all day so these kids
would get paid very little money stuck
in a room given a really hard number to
hit that they couldn't hit they would
get burned out and then they get turned
out and then the rest of the company was
the same way only it was even less
rational because you could get fired for
no reason at all in this did have a
little group of people of one we made
the boss and she would just fire all the
people she didn't like right because
they have these untrained managers he's
under train managers nobody got any
training at all so it's just like Lord
of the Flies right just take a bunch of
kids and put them in a room and let them
be crazy with each other right and one
of my favorite stories was when and when
they fired you they call the graduation
this is great this is a great thing and
we get these teary email saying hey
everybody just want you to know that
Derek has graduated we can't wait to see
where he's going with his next big
superpower Rockstar adventure it's like
dude you fired that guy right and you'd
look over you'd be like wait a minute
Derek's gone like and then you look at
his desk is empty everything's like
spinal tap drummers just they go up in
the Power Stone right like people and it
would happen all the time people get
fired all the time was like living in
Argentina in the 1970s just boom they
just disappear
so and then I realize they don't even
think this is a problem they think this
is great the high turnover thing was
actually like they would say you know
they would explain it by saying well you
know we're we're we're rock stars and we
can only play with other rock stars so
you know if you weren't a rock star you
got graduated right and this wasn't even
unique to them it came from net this is
from the culture globe but this came
from Netflix we're a team not a family
right this idea that you know we we need
to have any players in every position
but it's a telemarking right it's
customer support it's not you know
anyway it's more like it's just a way to
use a vendetta on people right the other
thing I started looking around and
realizing is they had this huge emphasis
on culture fit which I think it's become
this terrible human ism this really bad
euphemism which really means racism and
lack of diversity and it's a way of sort
of turning a negative into a positive
so look around there's no one over 30
like hardly except for me and one other
guy who wanted to become my friend we
used to go for lunch together when they
had to break up because people would see
us paired up what the two old guys right
we had have a man break up so uh but
they went and there were no people of
color like no black people we once the
first time we had a whole company
meeting it looked it was 700 people in a
room and it's like all just white kids
in their 20s and like not even a very
diverse group of white people like Klan
rallies have a wider swath of the
Caucasian population then we had we have
like one kind of white person it looked
like the kids you see on Cape Cod in the
summer like Cape Cod just bashed up the
whole population launched him into
Cambridge and they all landed in one
building right so I start realizing
there are really serious problems about
this like the industry in a way had gone
wrong in ways I wasn't as I didn't
understand Reid Hoffman at LinkedIn
actually brags about this so don't think
of your job as a career you're not
coming here to work for a long time
you're not gonna do what Lena Stovall
does and write a novel that's for 25
years are you going to you're going to
work here for a year and a half and they
were going to graduate you and you going
to go do something else right at Amazon
this so I left to write this book and
they hacked my computers and tried to
find out what I was writing and then the
FBI got involved is a great great other
story that's in the end of the book but
Amazon you know you walk out of a
confident grown people sitting there
crying at their desks right and I start
thinking like I've stumbled into a much
bigger story than I realized and people
start writing people read my book and
start writing
telling me these horror stories of
things like what I experienced at
HubSpot wasn't really all that unusual
in fact it's becoming the norm right
Jeffrey Pfeffer who's a professor at
Stanford wrote an essay when my book
came out why modern work tells you makes
people so miserable right say it's a
return to the work arrangements of 140
years ago not some a new managerial
innovation it's worth if you're in the
gig economy
god forbid you lose your job and now you
have to become an uber driver because
they won't even pay you as an employee
right they may force you to be a
contractor and VCS won't invest in your
company if it's a gig economy company if
you want to make your employees actual
employees right which kind of kills me
because ever has apparently ten billion
dollars in cash sitting in the bank that
VCS have given it but they won't pay
their their drivers as employees won't
give them benefits right when when the
drivers sued ubers spent 100 million
dollars to settle the suit to make it go
away which tells you how badly they
don't want to make people employees
right Amazon has people living in tents
in Scotland because they can't afford to
live near where they work and Jeff Bezos
charges them ten bucks a day ten pounds
a day to ride a bus Jeff Bezos is worth
70 billion dollars but he makes his
employees pay 10 pounds a day to ride a
bus to work so instead they sleep in
tents right so which happen is we've
created this class of people called the
precariat right who either get in a job
that then bounced every 18 months or
never can't get a job at all right and
antidepressant usage is up 400% suicide
rates highest in 30 years right so we're
making work fun like on the surface a
house why it was fun right we're given
given people this right but it's making
people miserable right which is this
weird kind of conundrum right oh and I
think the reason is we're taking away
all these basic things save for
retirement work-life balance a fair
share of the equity when HubSpot went
public they had a big party a handful of
people made hundreds of millions of
dollars and we all went to a party and
gave each of us a little bottle of that
fresh net sparkling the wine you know
the fake champagne and then they had a
girl checking off a checklist so that
you didn't take to like you couldn't
sneak back in and get your second bottle
of fake champagne anyway so they ask
yourself why is Silicon Valley changed
and I'm gonna try to get through this
quickly because I know I'm running out
of time b/c I think is the problem right
from 1995 to 2015 the venture capital
industry twice the number of funds twice
the number of firms four times the
number of active investors and four
times as much capital under management
if you go back five to 95 I haven't been
able to do this analysis yet I think
it's way way more dramatic right but
this is basically the beginning of the
dot-com explosion right Netscape's
IPO BC cumulative capital sixty six
billion to six hundred and twenty seven
billion in 2015 total VC investments
eight billion to sixty billion so you
just have a huge amount of money rushing
into this space right in search of a
return and the bottom of this new
economy is grow fast lose money go
public cash out right right so you know
all the focus is on customer acquisition
revenue acquisition buying top-line
growth lose as much money as you want
right I did an analysis recently for my
fortune column 60 tech IPO since 2011
they're still independent a lot of them
have been gone public and got taken out
or acquired right only ten have ever
made a profit right if you look at how
much money Twitter alone has lost it's a
two and a half billion dollars since it
went public right crazy but meanwhile
every one of these has created created
you know senti millionaires and
billionaires so these people are voicing
these really risky money losing
companies into the public markets
skating away with their money and then
leaving for it leaving you know the day
of reckoning will come right I think
there's also something else is happening
in the old days if you look back at the
early days of HP when H and P we're
running HP they saw themselves as having
four constituencies customers community
employees and investors and investors
came last right they wanted to have
happy customers they wanted to pay their
taxes and be part of the community they
wanted to take care of the employees and
make sure the employees had a good life
and could feed their kids and and you
know put their kids through school and
save for retirement that's all gone away
and now there's only one consistency
that Madison that's investors and we've
somehow taken it for granted in the last
20 years that this is the new normal
that the people who matter most are the
investors when really all the investors
are doing the VCS I spoke at a BC
conference races this joke did not go
over well aside you guys are the best
job in the world
you take money from one group of people
you don't take your money you take their
money then you give it to these guys you
work them like dogs by the time they
succeed you own all of their company and
you make off money right that sounds
like a great racket but that has become
the racket right
the other side effects of this are bro
culture income inequality and worse
right so broke out sir this was not
HubSpot but it looked like HubSpot the
CEO of house walk was like the world's
oldest teenager he's 47 years old still
loved to hang out with the kids and
where is like big funny hat on the Cinco
de Mayo party but they bros who invest
in bros who hire other bros and they
call it culture fit right they have this
frat house culture they have go for a
beer as the basis of hiring like I like
to hire someone another one of the beer
would have to work which is the
stupidest reason to hire anyone ever
right like like thank you and but they
will actually say this at hot spot when
I got higher they said I like to her go
I want to go is like I don't drink and
I'm never going for a beer with you cuz
you're an [ __ ] but but I still want
to work it right but no but they that is
like the reason they get to hire people
right and you're CEOs who have no
experience and they have no adult
supervision in the old days in the old
days being like Google even Google had
to hire Eric Schmidt or their VCS
wouldn't put the money in right now the
idea is no just let Evan Spiegel go at
it with snap right so you have this that
and then you're a biased one on every
vector age race gender right
HubSpot had like I said nobody my age no
one of color and then there were a lot
of women but they only got this high no
women in any power you look at the
management page I have a couple of funny
slides that I didn't put in here if you
look at go through a list of every
management team in tech white guys white
guys white guys and it looks like they
were all made in the same white guy lab
like they were all hacks from the same
kind of egg they don't even look like
different kinds of white guys right
incoming equality this is I think
another factor of skewing all the return
to those investors and letting them
skate away and not dispersing the money
out throughout all the employees for
example uber the taxi market is say
let's say it's a hundred billion dollar
market globally it's a hundred billion
dollars but it's spread among thousands
and thousands or millions of little
customer companies right and individuals
uber replaces that has a 60 billion
dollar market cap and that sixty billion
dollars will be in the hands of maybe a
hundred people right when they finally
go public eight men control as much
wealth as half of the world this number
came out recently a few years ago was a
few hundred which was already pretty
appalling right but now it's down to
eight
the other thing to notice I think since
we're at an open-source conference is
that - these guys are made their money
in the old world of clothes or software
which was probably the greatest racket
ever invented on planet Earth
right but most of them are techies even
Bloomberg if you count him right CEO -
worker compensation ratio this is a
really interesting chart because you see
it go back in 65 was 20 X and it crept
up crept up through the 70s through the
80s and then look where it Peaks 2000
the height of the dot-com mania boom
look who's making all the money the CEO
376 and they think ok the crash comes
everything will settle back down but it
doesn't it comes back down to 300 now so
it's basically it went way off the rails
and then stayed there and then worse all
right to recap I think the
financialization of the economy where
the finance industry now is 20% of GDP
leads to only investors matter leads to
8 men control half as much money as half
the world
I mean control as much money as after
well lead to the precariat this angry
mob of people who have nothing right
which leads to this brexit and you know
he who shall not be named right but the
precariat I think lashed out people
lashed out people realize they're
getting screwed and they lashed out at
the at the ballot box it's the last bit
of power people have is I may not have
any money I may not have a pension and
then enough health insurance that I got
one thing that even Larry Ellison has I
have a boat I have as much of a voter
I'm going to use it and I'm going to
screw you with it right so if we keep
going in this direction I think we end
up here this is a guy who made a lot of
money on Amazon one of the early
investors who two years ago said the
pitchforks are coming for us this is a
story from The New Yorker recently
doomsday prep for the super-rich which I
highly recommend you read Evan Osnos
wrote this thing about how people like
Peter Thiel are now bugging out for New
Zealand and making boltholes right
trying to escape from the mess they've
created like instead of taking their
billions of dollars and trying to fix
the system we have by paying taxes Apple
has two hundred sixty four billion
dollars in cash sitting outside the
country and won't bring it back unless
they get a special break why don't they
want to pay taxes and they complain we
don't have any stem grads will pay your
[ __ ] taxes right you know so you know
fix your schools right so instead
they're going to bolt-hole out and
they're going to live in New Zealand
going to live in Bunker's right
seriously
in Bunker's with their billions of
dollars which to me is insane right
which is another way of saying I came
around to realize Richard Stallman was
right right like after all those years I
made fun of Richard Stallman I'm like oh
my god I've turned into Stalin right I'm
56 years old now I become Richard
Stallman you're supposed to become more
conservative as you get older I become a
crazy Bernie Sanders liberal right but
like but I think saman did see this
Stallman saw what happens with Microsoft
where does that lead to yeah Bill Gates
becomes the richest guy on earth and you
have this income inequality you have
this disparity and you have this huge
mass of people who rise up and create
problems for all of us right we make
this joke on Silicon Valley I don't
wanna live in a world with someone else
makes the world a better place better
than we do and we even kind of make a
joke about how techies all talk about
making the world a better place my one
last message to use I actually think
techies can make the world a better
place but it's not by making snapchat
right I think it's by creating a company
that hires ten people right and pays
them really really well and so that they
can have a good life and a good career
and have a family and have kids and save
for retirement and if you make company
with ten people and you make one with
ten people and I make one with three
people because I won't do as well as you
but you know and they have a hundred and
ten you know we can basically make this
world but we can make the world we want
to live in right we can build the world
we want to live we can make the kind of
companies we want to work for that's
what I saw at canonical ten years ago
and I still think it's true today I'm
sorry for rushing so fast but thank you
and again I'm very very sorry for all my
old Richard Stallman jokes because it
turns out he was right thank you very
much